hello everyone I wasn't going to do any
more videos today but then Gary Kasparov
had a car accident and he was
interviewed by The Telegraph reported
early on Watson and during the interview
they played a chess game to see if
everything is okay with Kasparov said so
Leon Watson the reporter for telegraph
has the white pieces and Garry Kasparov
fresh from the car accident has the
black pieces we have d4 by mr. Watson
and Knight to f6 c4 g6 the Kings Indian
defense Knight to c3 Bishop to g7 we
have E for b6 now Knight to f3
we have castles Bishop to e2 and now e5
watson castles we have nice to see 6 +
b5 gaining more space in the center and
kicking the knight to e7 and here the
Telegraph reporter Leon Watson goes for
a very sharp bayonet attack with B for
Casper plays Knight to h5 preparing f5
rook to e1 and now a5 trying to break up
that pawn chain Watson is creating it on
the Queen side with Bishop 283 and now
b6 c5 is played and now a capture some
b4 and well here you there's really
nothing nothing good white can do here
because the well both of his pieces are
attacked and well he captures the pawn
Bishop captures than before and here is
part of just plays B captures on c5 and
well this Bishop here on before is
trapped
he has nowhere to go and in this
position The Telegraph reporter Leon
Watson resigned the game so yeah that's
the game that's the the newest game
Garry Kasparov played I hope you enjoyed
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here and I would like to thank
balancing me for a contribution to my
channel thanks a lot I really appreciate
it
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon